seemed agamous square in front of
Parliament is the beating heart of
Athens now a picture of emptiness even
more extreme than that seen when the
Nazis rolled into town eight decades ago
the one operating hotel on the square is
the plaza and even it doesn't look very
open in family nor the chi-x medical
code circus we are operating at 16 to 18
percent occupancy mostly with
international air crews from cargo flies
and some people who have chosen to live
in the hotel permanently at the airport
international passenger traffic has
stopped only a handful of domestic
flights still take off and land and that
has cut off the lifeblood of the economy
Greece had 34 million visitors last year
three times its population they
generated an estimated income of over 50
billion dollars that's more than a
quarter of the economy and gave jobs to
almost a million people this industry is
Greece's powerhouse and was key to its
recovery from a decade-long recession
the country was set for a repeat
performance this year by the end of
February we had already booked half our
capacity for the year now March and
April are lost and everything for the
summer has been cancelled we don't even
know if the airlines will operate the
industry hopes to salvage something of
the season and is asking the government
to lower sales tax from 24 percent it's
the highest in the Mediterranean a
remnant of Greece's decade of austerity
and it wants Europe to allow vouchers
valid for 18 months rather than cash
refunds for canceled holidays but demand
remains a problem coronavirus is still
ripping through Greece's main markets
receipts from over 90 percent comes from
international markets retzius says
greece will focus on attracting visitors
from the middle
East and the Balkans where governments
have so far successfully quelled to the
spread of the virus the government is
spending more than five billion dollars
subsidizing businesses and employees so
they can get back to work again when the
situation improves it's a gamble that a
return to normality will be a matter of
weeks not months jumps our applause al
Jazeera Athens